so we've all dealt with scams right
robocalls tax collection schemes random
Prince's who need a cool brand because
they're in a pinch it's it's honestly
endless but we've also all had that
thought of if I just had more time I
would totally screw with this guy but
we're all busy as [ __ ] so we don't we
hang up and we move on with our lives
but there is thankfully one twitch
streamer who does exactly that spends
his time creating content scamming the
scammers
[Music]
okay so this is kit boga he makes
YouTube videos and streams on Twitch
screwing with every scammer imaginable
what I want what I really really want so
tell me what you want what you really
really want people generally refer to
this kind of content as scam baiting
where you pretend to be a victim in
order to troll and gather information on
scammers and hopefully expose them and
when it comes to kit boga well it's
controlled chaos which starts with his
voice modulator that allows him to
pretend to be different people and
watching him go from an 84 year old
woman to a texan to a typical valley
girl all with the intent of wasting a
scammers time well it's honestly pretty
[ __ ] funny to watch hello I don't I
put my first one on there - it'll be
fine hold on just connect it why are you
don't need to do that why are you
yelling at me right now
you haven't that five hundred dollars
now well he's clearly having fun
screwing with these people the whole
reason he started doing it in the first
place well it's pretty personal
according to an end gadget article kit
bogus grandmother often fell for these
generic phone scams he gives one extreme
example where a woman would show up to
his grandmother's house weekly to clean
viruses off a MacBook that she barely
ever used once he realized how easy it
was for people to fall victim to these
scams he felt like he needed to do
something about it so in 2017 he started
uploading to YouTube and streaming on
Twitch and since then he's built up this
whole infrastructure in order to find
new scams
he's got the submission form that people
can fill out and it's basically a way to
document their experience with a scammer
and then from there he figures out from
the list of candidates who is gonna [ __ ]
with next and since he started doing
this he's picked up millions of views on
YouTube he's gotten so popular that
scammers recognized him on stream and
bail once they realized who their
doing with my husband went to the
bathroom you're gonna have to give me a
second you are [ __ ] you are your
prey
you are making a prank video in the
YouTube channel I made it
he called me big oh okay but how does
all of this actually work well his
background is in software development
and with the help of his community he
built this virtual machine that runs a
VPN in order to hide his identity and in
case you aren't tech savvy a virtual
machine is basically just one computer
pretending to be an entirely different
computer I don't want anything new you
you you you lost your computer that's it
Oh bro you really think I would have let
you connect to my real computer what's
my I the IP address that you got from my
computer is 192.168.0.1 a point of this
in kit bogus case is to throw up a
barrier between his main computer with
all its sensitive information and this
separate computer that he [ __ ] with the
scammers on and in some specific cases
he'll actually let one of these scam
artists take control of his desktop
letting them think that they now have
full control over everything before
showing them well
photos of naked mole-rats now here's a
lot of people sort of from like you know
from like the ration that maybe they
tease wait why you look why are you
looking at my mood folder like that is
very private or hell even letting them
reset the password on his computer
before he guesses it on the second try
all right let's see if we can press F to
unlock okay it wasn't that one
because what he's doing is so sensitive
he goes to great lengths to protect his
actual identity hell I don't even know
what his real name is which is pretty
crazy when you consider that he's
streaming to thousands of people now in
the early days he would go searching for
these scams himself intentionally
misspelling website names or held just
searching for technical support on the
second page of Google and well obviously
finding scams honestly the real reason
it's so much fun watching Kip bogus
dream is because of something we all
deal with right I barely answer my phone
anymore due to all these [ __ ] robo
calls so to watch somebody take the
fight to them it's [ __ ] awesome and
my favorite thing that he does is when
he pits to scammers against each other
that is not from the call right now
while it's fun and games for the most
part at the end of every trolling
session KITT boga does tell them that he
knows what they're doing and he's in
like Angry or condescending about it
he's pretty chill and honestly a lot of
the times they end up having a
conversation about why these people are
scamming you in the first place yet to
be honest with you it's actually above
this message and this is his game dude
thank you for being honest man that
props to you dude yeah I'm actually you
know planning to just get out of this
version so don't mind I'm here I'm just
waiting for my wages though his magnum
opus his most complicated troll to date
is a 10 episode 36-hour saga [ __ ]
with these scammers and the extreme
lengths they'll go to for some [ __ ]
Google gift cards it is honestly
incredible
that way all the money gets added to you
know here's the thing right I am now put
on the spot so I'm not gonna be able to
define irony not iron mm-hmm and I love
it for the [ __ ] opening all I do is
read and right now I could not tell you
for the left me with the word irony
means no it's kind of ironic that as a
trained journalist I don't know what the
[ __ ] word irony meets
[Laughter]